in this video we'll talk about the
triponema pallidum this is a high yield
video for USMLE step one stay tuned till
the end
triponema palliderm is the key causative
bacteria for the sexually transmitted
disease syphilis
so when we talk about the microbiology
behind this triponema pallidum belongs
to spirochites these are helically
coiled corkscrew-shaped bacteria and
they are generally drum negative in
nature they contains distinct diaderm
that means double membrane and they are
roughly 3 to 500 Micron long
one of the peculiar feature about the
spirochetes that they have endoflagella
endoflagella is one of the system which
one of the flagellar system which runs
between these two double membranes this
is very different from any other
bacteria flagella is generally protruded
out of the bacterial surface but this
particular endoflagella moves within the
membranes this allows this bacteria to
make a corkscrew-like movement
now let's talk about why triponema is so
important because this is the causative
agent for the disease syphilis syphilis
is a sexually transmitted disease
obviously it's a bacterial infection
and the key causative agent for this is
triponema pallidum that is why it is
very important from a pathological point
of view
the triponema pallidium bacteria can
make its way through the thick mucus via
twisting like motions and the
endoflagella helps in this process
generally they are acquired by direct
contact during let's say sexual activity
they can enter the host via any kind of
bridge in the squamous or in the
columnar epithelium so let's say there
is a small bridge in your skin and there
is a contact with the fluid that
contains triponema it can enter your
body
now let's quickly try to Breeze through
the stages of syphilis syphilis is kind
of like a deadly sexually transmitted
disease so it begins with the primary
stage which happens within the three to
ninety days after infection then there
is a secondary stage generally lasts for
four to ten weeks after infection then
there would be a latent stage where
things are completely okay and there is
no problem and there is a tertiary stage
which is like 3 to 15 years after
infection so in tertiary stages there
are a lot of problems organ failures and
multi-organ kind of infection happens
now let's talk about the phases one by
one in the primary phase of the syphilis
there are rashes and scars present on
the external genitalia and many other
places
so these sores are actually known as
Shanker
so if we zoom into one Shanker we can
see it has a raised border hard base and
a fluid field region and this
fluid-filled region is enriched in the
triponema bacteria so by mistake let's
say somebody touches the
a particular region so that would
basically take the bacteria with it now
these rashes are present in genitals
anas or even around the mouth let's say
during a sexual activity somebody
touches the penis with a Shanker and the
triponema bacteria would eventually try
to invade its way through any skin
breaches or also during oral sex or many
other kind of sexual activity this can
be transmitted
so triponema can board through the
membranes the mucus and eventually look
for the bridges in the membrane or in
the epithelial tissue one thing to be
noted that the triponema can be
transmitted from mother to baby during
the birth and in babies there are
different kind of symptoms like
maculopapular rash
there are hearing defects there are
neuroties and many other kind of small
morphological features that can lead to
complications in lateral life
now let's talk about the secondary stage
of syphilis in this case there are many
type of rashes developed throughout the
body there are also fever swollen lymph
node and many rashes which are appears
different regions of the body and these
rashes are distinct we'll talk about it
in in some time so generally at this
point of time the triponema moves to the
lymph node and that causes swelling of
the lymph node which is known as lymph
adenopathy eventually triponema can also
reach the bloodstream and cause a
systemic level response
anyway
um sometimes what happens is syphilis
infection is also transmitted during
blood transfusion
and in that cases things are
non-canonical Shankar doesn't develop in
that case
thank you
let's see what happens during the
secondary stage so obviously we talked
about the lymph adenopathy or the
swellen lymph node but alongside that
syphilis can eventually move to the
bloodstream
and they can also basically
uh
cause this kind of itchy and macular
rash
so there are different kind of rash some
are postuler which are filled with pus
there are some which are papillos commas
which are scaly hard rashes on the skin
there are also condyloma which are white
small bumps on the skin so these are
different type of rashes which one can
find in a patient with syphilis
and this is some somewhere around 6 to
12 weeks from infection
now this particular stage is very very
infectious
then there would be a time when the
infection is latent and there is no
signs and symptoms so it's kind of like
they remain in circulation but they
don't show any kind of pathological
symptoms people think that okay the
infection is kind of resolved
but that's the biggest mistake during
the treatment so basically this is a
latent stage not a cured stage
now their presence can lead to T cell
mediated Type 4 hypersensitivity
and that might lead to
secretion of several interleukins like
interleukin-1 tnf Alpha so it might lead
to macrophage activation as well which
sometime might lead to redness fever or
warmth but nothing major happening at
that particular stage but later on
one can see Gooma formation on the skin
now Guma is basically a mass of dead
swollen fiber like tissue which has
different type of
immune cells and fibroblasts together
so this kind of Gooma also has a
necrotic Center Center in in it the
tertiary stage of Syphilis is very
difficult
in this case Guma develops in different
regions for example it can develop on
liver it can also lead to
cardiovascular lesions it can also cause
neurological complications so the last
stage or tertiary stage is pretty
difficult and the survival chances are
low in this stage
now let's talk about the diagnosis of
triponema pallidum it cannot be gram
stained so it doesn't stain well with
gram staining methods though it's a gram
negative bacteria but anyway a silver
nitrate stain is better in otherwise
yellowish background they appears black
in this particular stain
now triponema Palladium can be detected
in a more deterministic way with the
help of particle acclimitation test or
tppa
in this case a fine RBC which is coated
with triponema pallidum antigens are
actually added in a micro title plate
eventually patient serum would be loaded
on these micro title plate patient serum
might have a bacteria against the
antigen against the triponema
pallidum so let's say that triponema has
invaded the patient so there would be
antibody generation because the antigen
is there in the patient's blood these
antibodies are the key thing that we try
to detect in this test
either the patient has antibody or they
might not have antibody so that is why
this particular test is very sensitive
so different titles are tested
in this case you can see an example of
positive versus negative title in this
case
there are other kind of tests which uses
fluorescence triponema antibody test
basically it has a antibody which can
detect triponema specific antigens and
has fluorescence attached to it so it's
a fluorescent level detection which is
kind of like also supportive along with
the tppa test
so the most uh
use test for triponema pallidum
detection is tppa test
now let's talk about the treatment
options for triponema pallidum there are
plenty treatment options since it's a
bacterial disease it can be treated with
antibiotic anybody can understand that
penicillin G is the drug after Choice
also erythromycin or tetracycline can be
used but has to be monitored with the
help of a physician so that's why Always
visiting a doctor at the early stage
increases your chance of curing because
if the infection is at tertiary stage
then there are a lot of complications
that has to be managed properly that is
why detection of this disease and
without hesitating one should visit the
doctor and try to initiate the treatment
as soon as possible that increases the
chance of perfect healing so I hope this
video was useful if you like to get more
notes and flashcards visit our Facebook
page all the links are provided in the
description you can also visit our
Instagram page for all the flash cards
then see you in next video don't forget
to like share subscribe and comment if
you like this video give it a quick
thumbs up and share with your friends
tell them about this channel thank you